Kylie has something for you a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for nest of
love kylie jenner is using her money for
good on The Ellen DeGeneres Show this
week
keilly started with a 27 year old girl
named Samantha who runs a women's
empowerment group in Miami called Madame
love she felt there weren't enough
female role models in her community so
she started this group where she brings
young women together every single week
to mentor them amantha gave up her
corporate job to do this and Kylie
wanted to make sure she personally was
also rewarded we have something for you
it's $100,000 for you
[Music]
and Kylie didn't stop there we are
giving each of you $50,000
Oh
yep that is a total that Carly just gave
you
750,000 dollars kylie plans to give away
more money later this week later in the
week with another 250,000 dollars this
all comes on the same episode that Kylie
talked about her billionaire status and
how her sisters feel about it I don't
know when we're like in a group chat
talking about like we should go on a
trip and then everyone's like Kylie
question mark you're gonna pay for it
all right just stuff like that of course
Forbes dubbed her a billionaire last
year thanks to her Kylie cosmetics
Empire and do they but do they really do
they expect you to pay for all the stuff
no they don't really know just my stuff
and though she jokes her family gives
her a hard time
they have been super supportive of their
youngest she made her own money for over
a decade she put it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well I
don't care who you are how you you know
but when you don't get it from someone
else that's helped me so it's not like
that was handed to her she figured that
all out I mean we all know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]